found your california dream home
good luck with that it may be gone by
tomorrow this is an l.a times story
the four bedroom house in north tustin
went on the market on thursday that
saturday vic and sarah
were inside checking out the mid-century
living room and debating how they could
remodel the kitchen in the 1.1 million
dollar listing
if they wanted to act they didn't have
much time offer were due
tuesday homes are selling at warp speed
nationwide forcing would-be buyers to
make snap decisions on what is typically
the biggest purchase of their lives
in california houses haven't sold faster
than at least three decades according to
data
from state's main realtors association
in march a homes median time on the
market in the golden state was eight
days that's
insane eight days the shortest time
period recorded by california social
realtors whose database goes back in
1990 in the bubble years 2003 to 2005
homes typically took more than 20 days
to sell in the hot market years
preceding the pandemic the median inc
medium time on the market
at times dipped further hitting a low of
14 days in 2017.
eight days you put the house in the
market within eight days of selling
that's insane
to be thinking about that and it's all
over the country you really don't hear
about any market where there isn't
bidding wars on your
house and then there's also these other
factors that have come into it if you're
a home buyer if you're building a new
home
is the cost of wood right now they say
that the cost of wood is so
high lumber because of the supply chain
issues that they've had over the past
year
that you if you're building a house add
on another 36 thousand dollars on
average per house
because of the wood shonda my wife is an
interior decorator
and if you want to order new appliances
right now she said
six months six months wait so by the way
right now at 10 o'clock i got
a uh interior decorator that's looking
at uh
one of the houses that we're looking at
to to help get the place to
fixed up and he says here's our limit
our limit's a minimum of two hundred
thousand dollars and this is what we
take
and honestly uh i if you say no to we
don't have a lot of time so this is kind
of what we're working with right now
that's like wait a minute what are you
talking about
like ten people you call they're all
saying the same thing yeah we're so
booked we can't when you need it is it
like a month from now two months from
now i know we need it like
we can't do that so it is a very
different
market today on who benefits from this
but the question becomes
how long this is gonna last the
challenge sometimes happens had a friend
of mine who was an interior interior
designer
and he would also come in and actually
do the work his best year in 2006 he
made 1.6 million dollars
for him that's a lot of money he made
1.6 million dollars in 2006.
do you know what happened to that 21.6
million dollar income three years later
the third crash 150 not not corrupt
not not 1.6 to 600 thousand dollars
to 150 grand nine percent 90
90 drop off so here's the if you're
listening to this
and you're one of the guys that's making
a lot of money more money than you've
ever made in your entire life
take whatever your income is this year
and divide it by five years
look at that as your real income if you
make two million this year
located as you only made 400 000 this
year over the next
five years if you're making a million
this year you didn't make a million this
year you really made 200 000
this year if you can look at your income
that way
you'll have it when the bad times come
because it's not going to be like this
for too long look no
there's two indicators when we talk
about inflation today we'll launch a
video
on inflation kai what's the title of the
video on inflation uh uh
the dangers of inflation and the futures
of america like how it affects right so
there's two things that affect the
market that controls the market who are
the two puppet masters of the market
fed fed and the other one is the
government right you got the fed in the
government
those are the two puppet masters feds
increase rates when the market is doing
very good
and the feds lower rates when the
market's doing what
or bad and they're scared about it now
the last 12 years the last 10 years
what have the rates been less than one
percent it's been less than one percent
since obama
to trump to now biden right janet yellen
indirectly says the rates are going to
go up and the reason why janet yellen
says is because she was what before
she was the chairman of the chairman of
the fed so she says the rates are going
to go
wait a minute who are you you can't say
something like that that's not your job
that's powell's job
so she got in trouble she had to come
back and apologize the next day
if she's hinting at the rates going up
whoever's buying anything today for
cheap money
it's going to change in the next 12 to
24 months it is not going to stay like
this forever people have to realize this
so
this craziness that's going on my
biggest concern is
a lot of people are buying ferraris
lambos
s 600s whatever they're buying with
money that they're not going to have two
years from now
what is the famous line that you say
save that what
save them save that money if there's
ever been a time to be very
careful with your cash savings because
they're gonna do this tax rates this is
not going away
they're gonna raise the taxes it's
probably not gonna be 39.6 on capital
gains
it's probably not going to be 28 for
corporate it's probably going to be 25
for corporate and it's probably going to
be you know 33 percent for capital gains
is still up what 13 on 20. that's a lot
of money we're talking about
so if you can get some cash right now
and sit on it
do so because in the next two three four
years
there's going to be some stuff that's
going to be taken by the when i'm saying
cash i'm not saying cash like you just
sit on cash because cash
inflation is going to hurt you i'm
saying put it in a place that you'll
have access to in the next two years
because
if you go in the spending spree right
now
it's almost like this you ever seen a
fighter that comes in
like it's these videos that do so well
get 50 million views the guy comes out
ufc and his pumpkin fingers and the
guy's face
and the other guys just staying quiet
right and there was one boxer back in
the days he would do the footwork and
would make fun of you and slap
prince yeah whatever his name was right
prince ali he would do all this stuff
and then one of the videos he's doing
this and he's like looking so good
next thing you know he's a little too
cocky he gets caught
drops i mean it's terrible that video on
facebook's got 40 50 million views and
everybody wants to everybody wants to
see cocky people
have a big fall it's something people
like they like to see trolls
with things yes people love that right
so all i'm saying is if somebody's
making money right now
more power to you man i'm excited for
you don't
over live your current lifestyle
thinking this money is going to come
forever it is
not going to come forever like this some
people are making lucky money
you know who you are if you're making
lucky money whatever income you make the
best way to gauge your income i know
you know the podcast we go into a lot of
different topics this is the best way to
gauge your income
take your income if you made a million
and a half this year
you made seven hundred thousand dollars
last year and you made three hundred
thousand dollars the year before
you know in my eyes what you're no
matter what income is three hundred
three hundred thousand dollars
if you made one and a half million this
year you made 1.6 million last year
you made 1.5 million the year before
guess what your income is you're a one
and a half million dollar guy more power
to you
so there's a big difference between this
guy living at the one and a half million
dollar lifestyle then the person that
made one and a half million this year
two years ago they were making three
hundred thousand dollars
the people that went from 300 to 1.5
with lucky money
they're going to get destroyed in the
next two years it's going to be very
very ugly in two years it's going to go
back to 2008 years when
you know you were buying 200 000 lambos
for 85 000 a guy comes to me
brings a yellow lamb and says dude just
take this from it so what do you mean he
says i bought the sack too just give me
eighty five thousand
i said eighty five thousand he says
why'd you pay for 250. he just bought it
for 250 year and a half ago
she wants eighty five thousand dollars
so there's gonna be a lot of those
opportunities next two years well that
means there's going to be good deals on
houses in a couple
plenty so plenty in the next two years
do you extrapolate that exactly let's
say you're making 50 grand then you go
to 120 grand and then you make 180 same
thing i do with the same thing
if i don't make the same money three
years i don't buy stuff on the number
that
i make three years gotcha i don't buy
stuff on on numbers i don't make three
years you just have to look at your
numbers that way yeah you can't get
caught up in that i made uh
300 grand this year but i usually make
80 grand look your name
guy i've been in this business for 20
years you know how many guys i've had
make
a hundred thousand dollars in a month
fifty thousand dollars in a month and i
tell them listen you didn't make fifty
thousand dollars this month you didn't
make a hundred thousand dollars this
month
you really if you take your six month
average you made a hundred thousand
dollars plus the prior
uh five months is 40 grand you made 140
divided by 5 is what
you made barely 28 000 act like you made
28 not you made a hundred thousand
dollars
but unfortunately guess what happens
when a person makes a hundred they get
the rolex
they get the ferragamo they get the tom
ford they get their stefano right they
get all this nice stuff that comes to
them
and next thing you know hey i don't have
any money two years later they got tax
issues
that i couldn't agree more i couldn't
agree more so because
especially if you're in an industry
where you can make some big commissions
like there's been some times where i've
made a huge pop
100 grand a month ridiculous i just put
that right you know when i bought
my first rolex
ask me when i bought my first roll pat
when did you buy your first roll
five years ago at 37 years old five
years ago do you know when i could
afford to buy rolex at 2012 years ago
at 25 years old yeah but i bought a
rolex five years why'd you wait so long
when did i buy my first ferragamo what
do you think first ferragamo shoes 550
shoes four years ago 29 years old my
first
jay's 30 years old i've never had a
jordan until 30 years old tell us why
the point it's you you cannot there
cannot be
this facade that you have real money
yeah there are people that have real
money there are people that are
making good money it's a big difference
if you're making the money
and you're living a lifestyle that you
cannot afford it's not sustainable
half the time it's let me see what this
guy's doing let me see what that guy's
doing for me
uh uh i'm about freedom i'm about peace
of mind i'm about
calm i'm about having a lot of those
things sometimes there is risk don't get
me wrong behind closed doors i got a lot
of my money that's also on risk because
i'm going for the big pop like you know
how we talked about earlier
when you said uh you know there's going
to be a lot of idiots that lose a lot of
their money in the next couple years
with whoever dogecoin or bitcoin or
whatever
and i said there's going to be a lot of
idiot millionaires there just is
but you know what is what is a real
idiot
somebody could have taken a risk and
he's worth 78 million dollars but
he was one day away from being a broke
idiot but people say what what a
freaking genius that guy's
just so you know a very wealthy person
is one decision away
from being an idiot of course this is
what people forget you see somebody that
won at the highest level you think oh
this guy must be a he's not he just made
a couple very good decisions and he was
a little bit more patient than his peers
yeah just like everything else in life
luck plays a huge role in everybody's
success and timing
you know being in the right place at the
right time so if you enjoyed this little
short segment from the podcast that we
did here's another short segment to
watch or if you want to see the entire
podcast
click over here take care everybody bye